And then the thing that we use in our office to kill the path that did directly we use the right machine
Has anybody heard of right technology before?
So I you started using right technology about 15 years ago
I studied this has to do with light frequencies
So real quick brief rundown by your dog physicists, so don't ask me too many technical questions, but all matter
Everything that you can see now to a smallest particle is simply energy that's vibrating this specific frequency that's what quantum physics teaches us
so
Life disease that those pathogens all the common infections in the verilia are also
Vibrating and a specific frequency if you can hit them at their own frequency, you can help kill them
Okay, you can help the immune system to tell you where they're hiding
So this is called energy medicine. I started studying this about 20 years ago, maybe 25 years ago
I didn't buy my first right machine till 15 years ago because at that time the whole information about the right was solely for treating cancer
The right is named after our guy royal raven right back in the 40s and 50s
He didn't work on light frequency to help kill cancer and he treated cancer patients to the University of Southern California
School of Medicine used to send him all their terminal cancer patients
That was really before they started using chemotherapy so they didn't know what to do with these cancer patients
The students keep a therapy came into advent after World War 2
Then the AMA past laws that you could not treat cancer unless you were using pharmaceuticals and all the cancer clinics
Then we're using nutraceuticals nutritional natural substances were shot down literally overnight
Chained down the door if you're kicked out of the country
That's where the Mexico cancer clinics came into being because many of those people like Gearson and
Poxie and such Bulltown to Mexico where they were free to practice the way they wanted and they practiced a nutritional therapy
Right didn't go to Mexico. He just gave up the ghost
He literally died in alcoholic living with his sister. I don't think he was ever married
And he all his technology was lost for decades until actually the federal government defense department picked up his technology and tried to use
frequency medicine to reduce disease and
And they actually did us a wonderful favor because they mapped out the quantum physics frequencies of every disease known to man
Which is one of blessing because of the freedom of information act. It all became public
So then we were able to use that with using right technology to help people get better
So it's a blessing
So all the information on right technology though 20 years ago was on cancer
Product life wasn't even really in the
Cross hairs at that time
I didn't have any cancer patients at the time
But I knew God was just telling me you're gonna get a right machine
You're gonna get a right machine, so I was studying about it studying about actually at the picture of the one that I picked out
And I did my research with this was the best one in the market right now. This is the one I wanted
At my front of my desk at my office
Until I had a patient who was actually a cop right to patient come in and say I have to talk to you right now
She looked like she had terror in her eyes. I told her in the room. She was I have breast cancer
It's in both breasts the doctor said it's the worst kind
You could get and if I don't do keyboard and radiation, I will be getting in three months. That's what they said
And I said
Okay, and what what do you want me to do?
She goes oh, you don't get it. I'm not doing the keyboard radiation my friend died of chemo five months ago
I'm not doing it. I would rather die if you can't help me I'd rather die
And I just knew right then I was birthed down. I said sharp. I'm getting it right because she don't even ask me what it is
You got to come down every day and do it and just she said fine. Just tell me what to do. She's still alive today
So since then that brought me into the whole journey of treating cancer patients. That's what I
Quit chronic went back to school gone to create functional medicine integrated cancer therapy
And that's by main piece of my
Then we started online patients about 10 years ago
Then we got into this whole body and piece and I figured that out things to the Lord
How do I how we started this whole room?
So the right has been a blessing
The right has to be the correct type the right has to be light frequency
So we use a brand called true right. I think I got a picture of it here
That's what we use for all our patients. So if a cancer patient's patient comes to us now or a chronic line patient comes to us now
Or we have patients that don't know what they have at least once a week
That fly in from New York or wherever and they but everywhere nobody can figure out what they have
If they have a
pathogen
No, understand it
Antigen is that which is the immune system is turned out against
So it's antigen that which the immune system is turned out against doesn't necessarily need to be a limited organism
it could be
Like heavy metal toxic city they have an autoimmune disease
And mercury is the antigen
Well, they don't need a right machine
so
We don't use the right machine with our patients if you have cancer or a biotoxin
Like Lyme disease. That's it in the autoimmune phase. That's where the right machine is in order
So our patients come to us there with us two full complete days
Tested and scanning them and what frequencies are going to work with them?
I personally write their program and they go home with the right machine that they're using every night while they're sleeping
So unless that cancer patient or a line patient is an invalid in a chair and never gets up and does anything
I want to live me during the day. That's my philosophy. I
Want you to identify with Lyme disease and that you have Lyme disease or the rest of your life
Not that you don't necessarily have Lyme disease. There's no more cancer in the rest of your life
But I want you to live. I want this to be your identity
Nobody better have a live tattoo here
Okay
You don't want to identify with this
You want to see your head of the sand you want to realize I got to do something about it
Make the steps to do something about it ask for wisdom and walk of that wisdom and be obedient
The trust that God's gonna heal you
So we use a right of every patient that is a chronic Lyme patient
That's a much more expensive program. So a person that's in a chronic stage not in a autoimmune stage
Often could take care of their problems. My daughter does not have a right machine
Could take care of their problems in their flare-ups with herbles because they're not in a T.H. One down at a stage
She gets flare-ups when she's under stress. She travels a lot. That's why because her whole immune system drops
So the light takes off and starts reproducing as she gets sick and gets a flare-up. She takes some herbles
And she relates to the immune response. Docs the line down and she's fine with it a day
She forgets the herbs in the hotel room or whatever that she calls me a year later. What was this ain't good?
Which I suggest you can make this down on your phone because I'm not going to be around
That's your life to tell
But she takes
Drag a lesson garlic and some other things that are tested her about it. Docs her out. Docs it out right away
She doesn't need it right
We use a right machine. I don't like that. I use a right machine. She had
Some skin cancer that we got with it. We still use a right machine every day
That's what the true right is. You go on their website. You know what I think
On our website
But we use the true right
That they use that
About a 24-inch bulb that
As a fate-pickish
purplish light
Remember I'm programming the frequencies that are going into that
So I'm said if you get into this lecture that my patients are 10 times harder than my cancer patients
And I say that a little bit of time cheap but a lot of sincerity because a cancer patient you can figure out the frequencies
That they need to kill that cancer
See cancer is your own cells that aren't going through
Normal program cell that they pop to us are in rapid replication phase
There's a reason for that we can usually figure that out
We can solve that reason and we can program the right for that cancer
We can usually figure out the right frequencies to use and that patient gets better
Most cancer patients come to us late stage 4. Nobody ever calls us and say hey, I just found out I have cancer. Can I come see you?
We didn't have one person he was a doctor from Southern Minnesota. That's it. They're medically. But so
But my pathogens are
Pathogens that are living organisms they're biotoxins and they want to do one thing
Survive
So the live bacteria and their co-infections all they want to do is survive and have babies
That's what they want to do they want to reproduce and they want to live so when you do things to try to kill them
They have this wonderful for them in a ability to morph their frequencies. That's how they stay alive
That's what a person infection is
Yes, a chronic infection in the hospital
Will they give them antibiotics and all this?
This this infection is antibiotic antibiotic resistant
It's because the frequencies it worked its frequency
It's a different organism
Not yet named but it's acting like a completely different organism
As it's functionally are a different frequency. So with the right program we have to write sweep programs
So it sweeps through frequencies
It's a pain and you have to change that person's program pretty regularly as that
It starts to work. So it's a lot more work